hey everyone how's it going my name's me
you go and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech and career and
life so today we're gonna be talking
about my computer science degree and
we're gonna walk through all the classes
that I took as an undergrad at UC San
Diego I am hoping to get through
everything in under 20 minutes but as I
was reviewing my transcript I realized I
took a lot of different classes so we
will try our best by going through my
classes year by year and talking about
what I learned in them as well as what
was memorable about them and I'm hoping
that this will shed some light on what a
four-year computer science degree at a
university is like I don't know maybe
you were deciding between going to a
coding bootcamp or going back to school
for computer science or maybe you went
to school for computer science and you
just wanted to know what the UCSD
program was like whatever that may be
I'm happy to have you and I'm ready and
excited to talk about my experience so I
went to the University of California San
Diego or UCSD for short from the years
2010 to 2014 to earn my Bachelors of
Science in computer science I entered
college without knowing what I wanted to
major in so I simply chose UCSD because
it was the best school that I got into a
little bit about UCSD college system
there are several colleges that you can
choose as an undergraduate student which
basically determines what general
education requirements you have to
satisfy as well as which dorms you live
in I was in war in college and I chose
that because when I read the Wikipedia
page for it the values and things that
the college stood for was really similar
to who I was in my own values especially
as a Libra we're in college is really
popular among engineering majors because
for those majors it slashes the general
education requirements in half which is
really good because engineering majors
at UCSD have so much coursework to get
through in order to graduate on time so
I didn't really need to take that many
GE classes and I also came in to UCSD
with a couple of classes done thanks to
my AP test scores which obviously I was
really glad because it got me out of
some math
classes I didn't need to take which I
know I would have done poorly in I
should also mention that UCSD was on the
quarter system instead of the semester
system so there were four quarters in
which you could take classes throughout
the year so let's get into the
coursework so I've talked in previous
videos about how I didn't start off as a
CS major at school so this first quarter
I was actually considering either
becoming a chemistry major or a
neuroscience major and this is because I
really liked chemistry in high school
and neuroscience just seemed kind of
cool because it was like brains and
thinking about how people think and the
science behind all of that so one of the
classes that I took was chemistry 6-8
honors now technically I had tested out
of this class with my AP scores but I
wanted to take the honors class anyways
to see if I could keep up with College
chemistry spoiler alert I couldn't it
was a really hard class and was
ultimately why I decided not to be a
chem major and then I also took psych 2
which was introduction to neuroscience I
never really took any college level
biology nor had I ever gotten close to
medicine or anything related to that in
high school so I wanted to take an intro
class to see if it would really interest
me another spoiler alert I hated this
class I actually failed it it was so bad
because I am terrible at memorizing
stuff and it turns out that memorization
is a really important skill if you want
to go into neuroscience or anything
biology related I also took this Warren
College writing program class which was
just a GE and then I took fill 10 intro
to logic now this was a key class
because this class opened my eyes to
computer science because at the end of
the quarter when I realized that I hated
both chemistry and neuroscience at the
college level I was kind of at a loss
for what the heck to even do in major in
so then I was talking to my friend who
suggested that I take a computer science
class because he knew how much I was
enjoying my logic class so that brings
us to winter quarter 2011 where I take
my very first computer science class
ever and this was CSE 8 a injured a
computer science with Java which also
had a lab course where you just go to
labs and programming Java and stuff I
also took chemistry 6b not honors
because I won't try to do that again and
I just need to fulfill my GE war in
college writing program B also GE
and then I also took CSE 91 which was
perspectives in CS C now I don't
remember taking this class at all to be
honest so I looked up what was part of
the coursework when I took it and what I
gathered from it was that it was
basically a class where each lecture
there was someone else who came in to
talk about how computer science can be
applied in many different ways some of
the lectures look really interesting but
most of the lectures were done by people
in academia who were talking about
complex computer science theorems and
equations to mostly freshmen who were
just learning how to write a for loop so
yeah that was CSE 91 and then I also
took math 20 C which was I guess
calculus I don't really remember that
class either next spring quarter was C
SCH B which was a continuation of intro
to computer science Java
I also took discrete mathematics this
quarter and I learned some useful stuff
that I still carry with me today because
it is useful like boolean algebra
Bonacci and number systems and I also
learned some stuff that I don't remember
what they are at all because I never
used them after that class like the
pigeonhole principle Gray's code and
karnaugh maps I remember I had a really
bad professor for this class but to be
fair most of my professors at UCSD were
not that good you'll see some of that
shades sprinkled in here and there
because I think UCSD CS program was very
theoretical it was very academic and it
was really focused on systems
architecture and lower level programming
which is like the complete opposite of
what I'm interested in high editing way
you go here I just wanted to stop and
clarify a few things so I don't actually
think that it was the professors were
bad or the courses were bad or anything
I think it was more that it just didn't
really match my learning style as much
as I had hoped for some people it really
does match their learning style
and their interests I think a computer
science degree experience really depends
on a lot of factor you know it depends I
also wanted to recognize the privilege
that I've had of going to an American
University and getting a computer
science degree because it has helped me
to become the software engineer that I
am today and it's giving me the career
that I've had to this day so with that
said back to the video I also took
linear algebra and statistical methods
that quarter which were also
requirements for computer science and
then I also took Chamber Orchestra now
some of you might know this but I was in
Orchestra through all of middle school
in high school so I wanted to bring that
a little bit into my college experience
and it was really fun but I had no time
to practice next moving on my second
year of college fall quarter of 2011
this quarter I took basic data
structures and object-oriented design
which is you know the foundation of like
all of computer science and then I took
class on how to debug which was so
useful we learned how to use a
scientific method to find bugs as well
as debugging tips and tricks and then I
took math / algorithms and systems
analysis where we learned about
algorithm complexity discrete
probability and recursion one thing that
was cool about this class was that it
was taught by this professor named
Ronald Graham who is the inventor of
Graham's number there's like a whole
wiki page about him and his number and
it was really cool to have him as a
professor and then I took intro to
neuroscience again because I failed it
and I didn't want an F on my transcript
one of the things that I think is really
cool about this day and age that wasn't
as readily available when I went to
college is that the materials to learn
computer science fundamentals like data
structures and algorithms is available
online and that's where I wanted to
thank the sponsor for this video
brilliant brilliant is a website that
has a ton of courses in the math and
sciences and computer science they're
entered a data structures class is way
easier to learn from than my college
class with beautiful illustrations and
interactive lessons each class explains
the concept
well to teach you how to think and each
course breaks down complex concepts into
easy-to-understand pieces go to
brilliant dot org slash hello my you go
and sign up for free and check out some
of their courses and the first 200
people to go to that link will get 20%
off of the annual premium subscription I
really hope that you take advantage of
this and brilliant thank you so much for
sponsoring now back to my degree all
right winter quarter of 2012 this is
when we start going into kind of some of
the lower level programming stuff
because I took a class called computer
organization and systems program aka CSC
30 this is where we learn things like
bitwise operations started learning
about assembly and the inner workings of
a computer aka the ALU buses and caches
I remember this class being pretty
difficult but it was really just a small
hint of what was to come and then I took
some easy classes to balance it out I
took music fourteen contemporary music I
couldn't find the syllabus for this one
I don't remember it but I'm pretty sure
it was an entire class about the Beatles
and then I took Phil 27 which was one of
the war in college basic GES about
ethics now you'd think that if you're
teaching ethics to a bunch of
engineering majors then you'd probably
teach course work around the
implications of engineering technology
and ethics but instead we learned things
about euthanasia abortion war and aid to
the needy which yeah like those are all
ethics problems but we wrote papers on
those things and I feel like it could
have been more useful if we did projects
relating ethics and engineering some
more now let's move on to spring quarter
of my second year so I took a class on
advanced data structures which built
upon my basic data structures class we
learned about binary search trees
balance trees various hashing techniques
heap Streep's priority queues and graphs
I also took a class called software
engineering which was taught by one of
our beloved professors Carrie Gillespie
and this is my very first like project
base class in fact this class every
order the professor decides that the
students will make a different kind of
application the quarter that I took it
our professor was really into CrossFit
and so all of us made a CrossFit app we
could choose what platform we wanted to
build on and it was really kind of
self-directed it was the first time that
we learned how to do it heard of
development and I learned a lot from
that class and is actually you know like
the first mobile app that I had ever
made I took the second part of the
ethics class that was GE and then I took
psych 161 which was engineering
psychology now this is actually one of
my most memorable classes in college
because I was really interested in the
subject matter the class primarily
focused on how human beings interact
with technology through audio and visual
cues my professor was a huge don norman
fan who wrote the design of everyday
things which is a very popular book in
the world of cognitive science and
design and then I realized that Don
Norman teaches at UCSD just not to
undergrad students so then I just
thought about how my professor just
completely idolizes one of his
colleagues and thought that was pretty
heartwarming so that was my second year
starting to get into some harder CS
classes and now on to my third year so
in this quarter I took algorithms in
which we learn things like depth-first
search and breadth-first search and
Dijkstra's and then I also took intro
slash theory of computation in this
class we learned about deterministic
finite automata and non-deterministic
finite automata and regular expressions
and what's natural and Turing machines
and this class was so so hard I really
struggled in it and I legit failed I was
also taking in class about programming
languages where I learned Oh camel and
Scala this is really just a cost to help
you adapt to different programming
languages really fast and learn about
all the different types that were out
there and then I took race and ethnicity
in American politics which must have
been a GE but I don't remember taking
this class at all next in the winter
quarter of my third year I took compiler
construction this class was really
really infamous at UCSD and people told
me that you spend at least 40 hours a
week on the programming assignments and
was
like a major reading class which I don't
believe in waiter classes because that's
when a lot of my friends especially
women dropped out and they got
discouraged from being in computer
science I just I just hate wieder
classes and I wish they didn't exist
in that class we basically made a
completely functional compiler and I was
like my first time doing a 48-hour
coding session which I will never ever
do it kid and then I took a class called
field study which was basically a way to
get credits for a part-time job that I
was working where I was coding super
super easy and then I apparently took
life sciences in the 20th century which
seems like it was about like evolution
and stuff again I I don't remember
taking this class so luckily I barely
passed my compiler class and then I
moved on to Spring Quarter in Spring
Quarter I retook theory of computation
because I failed it the first time and
it was just as grueling as a second time
but I was gonna make sure that it wasn't
gonna fail it again
I also took server side web applications
which was basically talking about
relational databases and how to create
sequel queries so I remember that one
being pretty easy and then I try to take
intro to AI and machine learning but the
course work was really intensive so I
ended up dropping it and then as part of
the CS coursework I took a class at the
management school about business project
management the group project was
actually kind of fun the end goal was to
make a marshmallow and spaghetti tower
that would get really really high and it
was all just around kind of going
through the motions of scoping her
project and researching a project
delegating things it was a fun class and
that was my third year and then in
between my third and fourth year I had
an internship at Intuit at the San Diego
office working on TurboTax which
basically got me my offer to work there
full time after graduation and even
though I had an offer I still had a lot
of course work to get through my fourth
year so I definitely could not slack off
so in the fall quarter of my senior year
I took operating systems learned about
FEMA for ease and such and then database
system principles which was kind of more
of the same stuff as my previous
database
then apparently I took a class on eating
disorders which like I don't remember
again at all
this was the quarter in which I took
some of those lower level programming
classes again that were requirements to
graduate and because I was like so
uninterested in these classes I don't
really remember them except I do
remember we learned about logic gates
and I think the project that we did in
this class was to create a Bitcoin
mining program and in the winter quarter
of my final year I took the second part
of those lower level programming classes
which was around computer architecture
we learned about modern processor design
and operation and there was also a lab -
this one - again I was so uninterested
in this topic that I don't really
remember the course but I needed to do
it to graduate I also took intro to
computer vision that quarter which was
actually pretty interesting because
Scott and I went to the same school
except he was majoring in electrical
engineering and knew a lot about
computer vision so he would help me out
on programming assignment which was kind
of like a cool moment for the both of us
because yes we were dating then because
we've been dating since we were in
college I did another field study class
for my internship to get some free
credits and then apparently I took a
class called corporate social
responsibility but it looks like I
dropped it probably because my computer
architecture classes were really
demanding and then in the spring quarter
of my final year I took mobile
programming which kind of was like a big
deal because that's what I ended up
doing for a job this was kind of the key
class because this is the very first
time that I did iOS programming which
you know became the rest of my career
but in the class we made an iOS app that
basically would replace I clickers which
were these kind of remote control
devices that you would use to vote on
things during class which were always
way too expensive
I also took product marketing and
management which was really cool because
we basically as a group decided to make
a marketing plan for a product or
company that already existed my group
chose sriracha from - foods because they
never market their stuff and we thought
it would be interesting and so I learned
a lot about sriracha that quarter and
then Jess which was totally GE but I do
remember this one
as we learned about big steps so then I
only had one class to take over summer
which was webclient languages which
basically was just making a website my
professor was kind of a troll and wanted
us to make a meme maker website because
memes were all the craze back in 2014
and I remember this was a group project
and there was like seven people in it
and me and one other person ended up
doing all of the work and it sucked so
then we left the group and made it on
our own what you know group projects
during college am i right anyways that's
my computer science degree I looked at
the current curriculum for CS students
at UCSD right now and it's largely the
same with the removal of compilers
getting that degree is one of the
hardest things that I've ever done and
honestly if I could go back in time and
choose another school and be able to pay
for it I would probably choose somewhere
else knowing what I know now about
myself I know what learning style fits
me best I know what interests me and I'm
not sure that UCSD CS program was great
for that but honestly I don't regret it
I met a lot of friends there I met Scott
there and while I didn't like the
coursework I think making me realize
what I didn't like led me to what I do
like I hope you liked this video if you
also went to a four-year degree program
for computer science then let me know
what your experience was in the comments
down below
and make sure to hit that subscribe
button and notification though I will
see you next time and hope you have a
great day wherever you are
bye